hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com hey and in today's video
we're going to analyze what just
happened on emc ngme we're going to try
to understand what it can be and what
can happen after that let's get into it
alright guys so i did a video this
morning i was telling you that things
were not looking good
because we were having a breakout on
bitcoin we were below
uh bam bam bam 298
on triple q and we
were just diving below
uh 13.5 on amc all right
so
um
i was telling you that the next support
level was nine
and we didn't reach that level this
morning we opened lower
and we made a massive massive move up
the day is not finished and you can
already see that the volume threaded is
much bigger than everything else we've
seen before since
this massive rally we had back in march
april
march
so
what does it mean first it's good news
because so let's see where we're going
to close the day
um but if we close the day in the green
so
above
10 roughly
it's going to be a green candle on an
increasing volume which is bullish it's
going to be detected by maybe some
algorithms that check this kind of
signals it's going to send them bullish
signals you know it's it's a good sign
even if the move is not big now
for reversal to come as you guys know we
monitor different situation momentum for
example uh and we try to combine that
with either a breakout or a candlestick
pattern or a moving average cars
crossover
here we don't have anything bullish in
terms of momentum the momentum is just
dropping i mean the only
bullish sign we could use is that we are
oversold but whenever the rsi is
oversold we need to wait um for support
to be hit so that it combines you always
need to combine at least two indicators
so here uh for me we didn't have a
signal because we were oversold in the
rsi but we didn't reach the nine support
so i mean it happens all right uh
it was not easy to buy a 10 10 was not a
support and it bounced here so it's like
that now let's analyze what we have
we are having a nice candlestick pattern
that is forming whatever it's gonna be
it can be different things from what i'm
seeing does for now the way it looks now
it's an inverted hammer all right you
have a long tail here a short body green
body it must be green i mean it can be
red but it's better when it's green
after a strong move down with an
increasing volume the volume is
important in this kind of reversal
patterns because if you have a reversal
pattern with that volume it means that
nobody cares about your reversal pattern
and it was not traded so you need to
have volume so we have the volume and we
don't know yet what is going to be
because guys if we close above
yesterday's open which was at 11 65
we're going to have a different
candlestick pattern we're going to have
a bullish engulfing which means that
this candle totally engulfs the one
before which is a stronger bullish
signal for now we have an inverted
hammer which means
that we had a lot of activity that we
had a strong reaction from both but that
we didn't manage to close at the top
it's still a reversal candle candlestick
pattern it's not as powerful as the
bullish engulfing
so it would be better if you close above
11.65 to trigger more buying signals on
algorithms that detect these patterns
it's quite easy but you have a lot of
traders that do that that combine
candlestick patterns with whatever rsi
whatever here we have a nice candlestick
pattern in with an oversold rsi so for
now i mean a candlestick pattern doesn't
give
always good results but it's a good sign
then
what is interesting to see so once again
if it finishes with a bullish engulfing
it's stronger what i like to see guys is
when you try to understand what happens
so i heard about
margin calls a lot
this recent days and
what i'm saying is that those margin
calls they usually occur in a strong
bull market whenever the
global market dips here
it doesn't look to me like a margin
called because it moved together with
triple q we had to move up on triple q
and a move up on amc let's go in a five
minutes time frame just to understand
what happened here so on amc on the five
minutes time frame what is interesting
is to see this massive volume here as
you can see
ah sorry pam let me do a do it again bam
bam bam okay so here as you can see
the strong volume happened at 6 4 20 all
right in my time zone 420
all right so here you can see triple q
was going up together
with amc so for this reason it doesn't
look like a margin call unless it's a
margin call because of a short position
it's possible but i mean to me it's
natural buyers that jumped in probably
algorithms
um
not sure what triggered this maybe
let's try to see maybe this break out
pum pum pam because let's be honest
everybody is kind of waiting for this
reversal
so maybe you know it does work out here
triggered algorithms i don't know i
don't i don't know it's very hard to
know exactly how they work but probably
something triggered by us all right and
i don't think it's short covering i
think it's natural buyers
uh especially at this level shorts
rather cover higher they don't buy low
they buy high whenever they have no
other choice so
what can we say from that
i mean it's good to see it
but we need more for this pattern the
way this pattern should be traded it's
basically whenever you have a
candlestick like that you can divide it
in three
uh
three
zones so i didn't make them even but all
right something like that
okay
and you have here it's the selling zone
okay here is the buying zone
and here it's the
indecision zone all right
so buddhish neutral bearish
and tomorrow so let's wait for this
pattern to finish first then we can
divide that in three zones if tomorrow
we open here we are bullish if we open
here this pattern is invalidated so
below
you just divide that in three so below
roughly 10.8 if we open tomorrow below
10.8 now let's make it precisely this
candle start at 10
goes to 13.5 so it's 1.2 roughly 1.2
plus
980 exactly so 1.25
it's
all right so if tomorrow we open above
1105
we are in the neutral area and we are
i mean neutral not bearish anymore if we
happen below 11 let's call it 11.
it's not very bullish for tomorrow and
if we open above 12 tomorrow then it's
very bullish and probably more
algorithms will jump in this trade so
it's not easy to trade because of the
huge volatility as you can see this move
has been
sold right away at what level
not really a big surprise at the recent
support level that is now resistance
around 13.5
i was looking at this move
of course i didn't think of selling my
shares
but
um
this could be a level
for those algorithms that jumped in to
take profits because they are very short
term
now we're waiting for a real reversal to
happen and the only thing that for me i
mean i didn't post an alert
on that
and i posted some alerts this morning
and i
i showed you guys on in my discord many
stocks where we are close to strong
support levels and i was saying that
whenever triple q reaches 280 then it's
the right time to go to this stocks
right because i like to combine what i'm
seeing on the global market with
what i'm seeing on the single stocks and
here
we are a little bit in the middle as you
can see all right so maybe
we don't need to go to 280 for uh the
bounce to happen but at least at 280
it's very likely that a lot of bears
myself included will
uh take profits i will have a decent
short position on triple two so that i'm
protected on my other investments
and i'm gonna take profit around 280 i
posted this this morning in my discord i
didn't take profit yet
um
so i'm sure there are more traders like
me that are gonna take profit around
this area because it's to me the natural
support
so let's see
uh let's see here what happens but as
long as we didn't reach this level i'm
still gonna feel like um we are not out
of trouble once we reach that and we
have a strong bullish reaction maybe the
correction is behind us i said maybe
because there is an alternative scenario
that is ugly guys
that could go to 220 you know a massive
you know move down a strong bur market
for the past six months why am i talking
about that
because we have some signals i showed
you that many times in my other videos
u.s senior yield inflation rates going
higher dxy all of that is not good we
also had
some massive massive moves down
on some major uh market cap such as
facebook manage 30 or 40
netflix
uh those events are not random all right
those
events usually happen
before you know the early signals of bad
things all right whenever you have one
you're like um all right this was maybe
just you know
uh something
uh just about this company whenever you
have a second one you start to think
whenever you have second one plus
many bearish signals in the global
market plus an environment that is very
very
fragile
you start to think about
is it is it happening and i hope not i
seriously don't know i'm bullish you
know just because this is the the way
things are stocks go up right so
i believe it can go higher even if it's
a bit
uh you know some of them are overvalued
and that is same but
i still believe we have uh you know a
strong economy and that
beautiful things can happen
you know we have innovation we have you
know a lot of sectors where we can
create produce and you know do great
things but um we could also find
ourselves in a longer correction
you know that could be called the market
so i hope we're not there but it's
possible and the last thing that i'm
very worried about is what is happening
on the crypto
market
uh we don't have the clothes below so
this is bitcoin chart
weekly time frame
we don't have the clothes below 29 000
we went we dipped to 25 but we didn't
close below so it's kind of
the only thing i'm like all right
at least we are holding here but i told
you about those early signals what do
you guys think about what is happening
with luna and terra guys 40 billion usd
of market cap vanished right so this
money
is of course lost by investors that are
gonna you know unwind other positions
and it's not good you know
so we have a systemic risk on the out on
the stable cons as well because of terra
which is a stable coin that basically
got de-pegged we can check
that that quickly guys
terra usd so it's the ust usd bam
0-3 so you see the peg didn't hold at
all
this was supposed to be equal to one so
it shows you that stable coins are not
stable anymore
uh
i'm worried
about the usdt
usd
that started to be attacked
guys
okay look at that it was a real attack
on the on this peg
hopefully we're back
but
this attack is dangerous right it's
dangerous if the usdt usd peg
breaks
bitcoin
will go to levels i don't want to
imagine if bitcoin goes to this levels
you know how much
money will disappear
and this money that disappears from the
crypto market is you know sucking off
the flows from the equity market so this
is all related so this is one more sign
that is really you know we had at really
at the limit of you know
is
the confidence of investors gonna be
totally lost or not all right here we
can see investors are losing a little
bit confidence in the crypto market but
we have some nice reaction as you can
see for now i mean
we are we're coming back here we have a
nice
um hanging man here
the volume is huge
growing again but it was on a red day
now it's green
okay i don't know what the thing is it's
just the situation is very very
difficult
um
you know this is when i should tell you
stay close to shore guys this
expression actually comes from
uh a former bus that was telling us that
when whenever the market was moving like
crazy he was selling he was saying we
expect a lot of volatility up ahead stay
close to shore which means don't try to
be a hero in a day like that don't try
to beat the market because
it's mostly about luck in this kind of
situations you know if you day trade in
this kind of situation is very very
difficult
it's better to take a step back
and to you know find really the key
levels and just to try to make some
trades around those levels this is what
i'm doing i'm not training a lot um you
know observing i'm having a rather
flattish position i'm ready to you know
take profit on my short position which
means that basically i'm gonna have my
full long position coming back
uh
which could help me to you know make
nice profits if we bounce
uh but for now i'm scared i'm scared
about what can happen and once again
we're at the limit so to conclude uh
let's see where imc is closing but we
have nice signal this is a good signal
that is sent from the meme stocks to the
equity market which is you know parallel
market i could say it's not the same
investors not the same uh
mechanics that are implied so i'm happy
to see that
um
it's a good sign but it's not enough yet
we need to see where we close today
where we open tomorrow all right so
remember that if we open above 11
tomorrow it's good if you close above
11.6 today it's good as well so that's
it for today i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're going to be the first
to know when i upload anything new and
stay close to floor i'll see you guys